ううっうぅうううおおおおおお
今から日本語の講座を行います
あ山本さん論タイムノーシーですどうですか最近やオフィスワーカーがちょっと多くて
気分ダウンです
なるほど僕は逆にブレインストーミングのミーティングがありすぎてモチベーションが
何
ないですしかも last train なんでワークライフバランスがとれないです
japanese ワークスタイルってやっぱりハードですよね
やべりータフですねプレミアムフライデーはいいんですけどプラスアルファでコーヒー
タイムも欲しいですよね
カジュアルでフレンドリーな感じがベストですもんねあいうは next ミーティング
でプロポーザルを出したらどうですか
まあ
イスアイディアですねうまくいったらロビーにあるスターバックスの低下をとをゲット
できるかもしれませんね jba i hope
日本がすぐにこうなっているから面白いですね yes
dl
あのなんて言ったらいいのかなーこーしかしどうなんだろうほんとねなんかさぁ他とは
ちょっとニャーでも分かった
あれっさて a
少子高齢化をどうしましょうか一つ提案してもいいですか
どうぞ所得税と消費税を少し下げたらどうですかしたら1本人はもっと貯金して一人ぞ
子供を育てて大学まで送れるようになると思いますが
のこのこ良い低音ですねうーんしかしそれだと年配の方の年金はどうなりますか
これをよく考えたほうがいいですよみなさんここにいるメンバーは全員そろそろ引退
です逆にあげた方がいいと思いますが
敏邦俺とや年配の年貢
員の方が先ですね僕たちじゃっ村も挙げる方針に賛成ですしかしに従来の本教がかなり
心配です大丈夫ですデータを確認しましたが若い層は滅多に投票しないよ税を上げる
方針が決定いたしました
tan
わーすかいとぅ usp エラー
per ears are ready to do sp プティングソープ
ローラーし
プーチ救えして立っ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇすびばれっじ
オーダーは ok
ロードスポスティングもヌー
ni